AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME...
♪ CATCON, CATCOFF ♪
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT!
MOVE OVER, COMIC, THERE'S A NEW
CON IN TOWN-- IT'S CATCON.
THAT'S RIGHT, AN ENTIRE
CONVENTION DEVOTED TO CATS!
THE AMAZING TWIST: CATS AREN'T
ALLOWED IN.
SUCK IT, CONCERNED KITTEN!
YEP. THE FI...
>> THAT'S TOO BAD.
>> HARDWICK: NO, (BLEEP) THAT
CAT!
(BLEEP) THAT CAT!
>> WHOA, HOMIE.
>> HARDWICK: THE F...
THE FINE PRINT SPECIFIES THAT
CATCON IS NOT A CONVENTION FOR
CATS BUT FOR CAT PEOPLE.
UH, SO IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU CAN
GET A POWERFUL CONTACT
DEPRESSION IN THERE, SO EVENTS
ON THE CATCON CALENDAR INCLUDE
PHOTOGRAPHING CATS-- IT LOOKS
EASY, BUT IT'S NOT OR GOOD-BYE,
DOWDY, HELLO, GORGEOUS,
DEBUNKING THE CAT LADY MYTH.
SO, COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO
COME UP WITH AS MANY
CATCON-WORTHY EVENTS AS YOU CAN
IN 60 SECONDS.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, BLAINE.
>> PEANUT BUTTER, THE WIDOW'S
FRIEND.
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: UH... JEN.
>> UH, GET A TUXEDO CAT SO
SITTING AROUND IN YOUR OLD
WEDDING DRESS WON'T SEEM AS SAD.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
C-COLTON.
>> FROM LITTER TO GLITTER: HOW
TO TURN YOUR CAT FECES INTO FUN
PARTY FAVORS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, BLAINE.
>> LOVING MONDAYS AND HATING
LASAGNA: DEALING WITH YOUR CAT'S
DYSLEXIA.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
COLTON.
>> CAT RAPS: RAPPIN' WITH CAT.
WITH SPECIAL GUEST MC SKAT KAT.
>> HARDWICK: YES! AMAZING.
(BELL DINGS)
>> AH. MY BUZZER'S BROKEN.
>> HARDWICK: UH, YOU'RE FINE.
COLTON.
>> HOW TO PLAN THE PURR-FECT
FELINE (BLEEP)FEST.
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
JEN KIRKMAN.
>> HOW TO KEEP YOUR CAT FROM
JUMPING ON THE BED AND
INTERRUPTING SEX.
OH, WAIT...
>> HARDWICK: OKAY. POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
COLTON.
>> DOG PEOPLE-- (BLEEP) THEM.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS!
PERFECT. THAT'S THE END OF
CATCON, CATCOFF.